they'll take their swings off of keegan
aiken
who was named eastern league pitcher of
the year back in 2018
[Applause]
stewart looks like he's going to record
all three outs of the first
makes the grab two out walk doesn't lead
to anything
orioles coming up against garrett
coleman the yankees are also helped by
the fact that
they have their race going they have
their best pitcher going garrett call
but
in his final our last two starts he has
not been the pitcher that he wants to be
3-2 sliders cut out a missed he struck
him out
you can also do that pitch bad to their
strengths and if they're looking for
fastballs on the first pitch you can
expand the zone
did he hold up no he did not so that's a
nice start for garrett cole
the orioles go down in order he strikes
out three
good pitch by keegan aiken striking out
sanchos
well doesn't matter strikes him out
anyways
two strikeouts for keegan aiken in the
inning
strike three garrett cole uh struck out
all four orioles he's faced
the two two strike three back door
breaking ball froze him
of the six straight outs cole is
recorded five have been by strikeout
continues to go to work
aiken picks up strikeout number three
another good change up
well the youngster's got the all-speed
pitches of going with
that plus fastball of his
pitch home and his pitches are working
well here greg he uses a fastball to get
voight to chase it's three up three down
for keegan aiken
well we go to the bottom of the third
scoreless
garrett cole has phase six retired six
and struck out five now here's garrett's
three
two struck came out swinging he threw a
fastball
right down the pipe thing is it was 99.
swing and a miss strikeout number seven
for cole
swing and a miss he's retired nine men
in a row and struck out eight of them
that's been the difference maker right
there that change up
there he spots it over the outside
corner another strikeout for keegan
aiken he's got sanchez twice
we go to the bottom of the fourth cole
has is about
as dominant a beginning as anyone could
ever have
iglesias swings and drives the ball into
left field this one gets down for a base
hit
iglesias charges around first as they're
still chasing it down at the track
he digs into second and will hit the
brakes
now here's the 2-2 slider
did he get him he got him so that's
strikeout number nine
although not as quote-unquote dominant
as cole was matching call zero for zero
another strikeout for keegan aiken well
cole is racking him up and aiken
is too back to back walks with two outs
and that means that torres will have an
opportunity to bat here
torres hits this one out to right
stewart makes the catch going on to the
warning track
swing and a miss and it's the second
time that aiken has gotten him off the
fastball
eight strikeouts for aiken leaves a
runner at first in this scoreless game
good block by severino throw down at
third safe
and the orioles want to have empires
take a look at this one it almost looked
like there was a little bit of gap and
the cleat came off after it was
initially on the bag
out dj stewart the 1-0
stuart it's a high towering fly ball to
deep right field
frazier is back in front of the wall
he's looking and it
is over the top of the wall and gone on
to the flat
cord that's the way to get your first
hit dj
stewart a towering fly
deep into the baltimore night and the
bases are full of orioles
with two outs in the sixth
a swing of a line drive center field out
for a base knock
alberto scores here comes one more
orioles get two mount castle to second
base
it's a three-nothing lead for the o's
ruiz he is the eighth man a hit in this
inning against cole over shift is on the
pitch
and then his ripped bear down the right
field line past the bag
hit the ball boy out there who actually
picked it up
the ball boy wide of the tarp picked it
up
but a run will score mount castle and
ruiz will be awarded second
on a ground rule ball boy impeded
double a bizarre ending to the play but
it's a run scoring extra base hit
all the same with
two on and two out yankees in need of a
big hit
swings at the first pitch and grounds it
softly to third
rui steps on the bag and that will do it
dj stewart
who had the initial salvo off of coal
harry swings it belts one high in the
air
you can forget about this one hello utah
stream
won't you have a little breakout game dj
and he has done it tonight two home runs
and this one is
melted frazier's one for three
high fly ball right field fair ball
that's gone it's gone a home run
the other way for frazier and the
yankees are on the board at
6-1 baltimore
and here comes dj and he got him
on a slider down and in big strikeout of
paul fry against one of the toughest in
the american league
so they're gonna go to cesar valdez who
has been warming up in the bullpen
luke boyd hits with two on and two out
scooped up by iglesias the flip to
alberto
in time ball game over orioles win it by
a 6-1
score